hey how's it going guys Matt here with
code Tech tutorials today we're going to
be looking at a little sample of a skill
tree as requested and well the hardest
part about this for me is just coming up
with a design basically I can I could
spend days years even hypothesizing
skill tree designs and this really has
nothing to do with coding so the big
Menthol sink for me is just coming up
with the design so without any design
we're just going to make up something so
I've got this little notepad here let's
come up with some theoretical design and
keep it super simple let's say we're
playing a let's say we're playing a game
and in this game you do some sword
fighting so you have swords all right
we're going to keep it that simple
thank you
how would we do this we could say we
need points and you need to put at least
one point into each obviously you can't
take both of these you have to take one
direction or the other that's kind of
the point of the tree but this should be
enough to give us an example to code up
one two three four we're gonna work with
four points and allow you to go down
this tree with those four points so four
points to spend on tree
all right now of course you might have a
leveling system or something like that
that gives you a point when you level up
or however you want to do it totally up
to you it's funny how teach me how to
code basically just turns into design
something that has nothing to do with
code I don't care how you design your
stuff that has nothing to do with coding
really you design it how you like it how
you want it and uh I could show you how
to code it but do I really need to
design everyone's program for them no
nor do I want to that sounds miserable
all right so with that in mind let's
make some structs so so we'll make a
skill tree or we'll make uh sword skills
tree there's several different ways you
can do this there's probably a good way
to use like a balanced tree to do this
but that's going to be a little rough
around the edges so now we're hard to
visualize rather so we're going to do it
in more of a cascading way so first of
all we need all these possible skills in
a struct now there's a couple ways I can
think of doing this we could brute force
it and we could just have all of them
available and then we could have some
sort of controller that only allows you
to take the proper one yeah that's
probably the way I would do it off the
top of my head and there might be
another way to do it where yeah I guess
for this simple of example brute force
is probably fine so
if you get if you pick uh sword skills
or sword specialization
we could say that this is a form of uh
skill tree
so let's go ahead and do that let's make
another struct called skill tree
and this is basically just going to
interface and we're just going to make a
void gain skill equals zero let's make
this virtual
let's put a Destructor in here
I'm not gonna worry too much about
following too many rules we're really
just going to get this done in a bare
minimum type fashion So eventually we're
going to have another struct let's just
call this our player character
or swordsman rather it's called
swordsman and Swordsmen is going to have
a field private field called skill tree
and we're going to make this a pointer
and we'll say chosen skill tree so
basically what this means is this could
be null which will mean they haven't
spent any points or if it's filled out
you could pick a different skill tree to
go down but you can only choose one as
you can see there's only one thing here
but it could be potentially set back to
null and reset and we can all we also
probably want to have points available
uh so we'll do that our skill points
rather so with a potential number of
skill points and that sort of thing we
can also have a let's do a level up
function
I'm going to make this private because
this is going to be called internally
when you get another experience or
something along those lines and I think
we're just going to inline all these
definitions that way we don't have to
resay everything twice
all right so on a level up your skill
points goes up and what else happens uh
you get to choose skill so let's make
another function called choose skill and
this function might be a little bit
bigger because it's basically going to
prompt based on your skill points and
we'll also have and uh points spin now
all these are going to default to zero
so let's just put that right in here
and this can start as normal now we have
to decide are we going to force the
person to choose a skill when they level
up or do we want to wait until they say
okay I'm ready to level let me choose my
stuff I think I'm just going to force
them right off here
with juice and just call choose skill
and this true skill is going to do most
of the cascading type function here and
it's going to be based off of this the
skill tree but we should also be able to
delegate some of this stuff to this
function here like when you go to choose
a skill it should be able to look at the
tree that's instantiated and maybe do
some stuff here so you can kind of
decide where you want to uh do the work
if you will and we'll incentive choose
skill we'll call this spin points or
spend points
trying to make design decisions on the
Fly here with more stuff now this is
where things could get a little bit
tricky because well basically you just
have to make a lot of design decisions
the majority of this is design decisions
not actual coding
so it's more of getting a proper flow
chart and deciding how you want things
to go once that's all deciding decided
you can kind of massage the code to get
it to work of course good coding skills
help here but I'm I'm pretty well
convinced that coding is like 99 design
and one percent actually knowing how to
code so you don't necessarily even need
coding skill to code theoretically you
just need to be able to come up with
stuff that you want to put in the code
at least that's how it is for me because
sure I can type code all day but
it needs to actually do something proper
or have a point so that's where the
design comes in and I think a lot of
people especially new coders kind of
miss that point so as a swordsman you're
also going to probably have some skills
I think we're just gonna have like a
damage stat and we're gonna assume you
have a basic weapon because obviously
this could get very quickly get into
equipment and all that stuff will start
as damage zero or maybe damage one and
that can increase as they level stuff up
we'll just call that end let's have an
attack function here and we'll have to
decide what the attack function does and
ultimately it's going to prompt based on
uh the potential impacts you have and
some of those are going to become
available from this sword special so the
logic in here is going to get a little
complicated pretty quickly
but that's okay
all right so let's say we get to this
spend Point method and we basically just
want to go uh field tree
chosen skill degree
gain skill
and that's going to run this method and
we need to implement it for each skill
tree and this isn't going to allow us to
make multiple skill trees like for
example we could have an ax one later
and you could set that as the one and
have that beat against skill so we're
only having one not only just the sword
special for simplicity's sake and we
just need to design this gain skill
based around our little chart now here
is our chart once again it's assumed
that I'm kind of assuming here that you
get the sword specialization
automatically like sure it might count
as a point as the first point but also
you kind of are forced to choose it if
you go in this tree like you got to
spend your first point there so we're
gonna have like uh some booleans here
we're gonna have bold
um
plus damage full uh Power Attack double
strike
and
and weapon block and on the other side
of the tree we have accuracy
stable strike
past attack
and quick swap some hypotheticals here
now we want these all to start out as
false so we need to make sure that these
are all false I'm just going to do it in
this way there might be a cleaner way of
doing it but I feel like this is pretty
clear that they all start as false and
now we're going to need some little
helper functions in here as well and of
course a game skill overridden to set
all this stuff we could even go as far
as to make these private so that people
can't just change them at will but you
know it's already private in The
Swordsman so maybe that's good enough we
don't want to over engineer this too
much so let's implement this game skill
put the override keyword in there and
then this is where some complicated
logic is going to start lie
because it's assumed okay you either
have to choose plus damage or accuracy
you can't have both because that's the
way the tree goes either go left or you
go right you can't go both directions
it's kind of the point here
at least in in this case of the way
we're designed maybe yours will allow
you to go down both sides of the tree
that's fine if you want to do that a lot
of a lot of games do that for stuff you
just have to make sure you meet the
prerequisites so
we could probably go ahead and you know
the spin point is a little bit redundant
we could just get rid of it and put that
right there because this is I think it's
only going to stay a single line I'll
just uh calling this gain skill but also
we need to make sure that a skill tree
is actually chosen so that's actually
kind of important so let's put a little
quick if here and say if
um not chosen skill tree so if it's not
filled out still null then we'll just
basically Force the user to pick one but
we know right now that there's no choice
uh so normally we'd have a branch here
and have you know prompt for some user
input maybe they got a click button and
choose a side or something like that but
in our case we're just gonna say you
know there's only one choice so you're
gonna have uh sword specialization choke
and we're just going to fill it out and
say
chosen skill tree equals
new storage specialization so just
wanted to reiterate that if you have
multiple this is the point where you
would say if you haven't chosen a tree
yet you need to choose a tree and then
you can continue and it's going to be
the same with this if you know you
actually have to have a skill tree
chosen to gain a skill
so in our case this second if is a
little redundant because it's kind of
reinforced instantiated anyway but we
basically just want to make sure we're
not doing some null reference so it's
just good practice to set something like
that up to begin with now I'm getting to
the point where I'm starting to think
about experience points and how the
leveling is going to work and it uh it
really gets over complicated very quick
we can just we're just going to assume
if we make an attack all right let's
assume if we make an attack at the end
of that attack we are going to level up
all right because we're going to
simplify it here normally you would
maybe you know there's a bunch of the
whole combat system to work out here too
or a whole experience system will work
out or whatever you decide to do for
your game or whatever you're programming
and I would be here an extra four hours
designing that and it's not even
important to the example we just need to
actually level up so we're gonna have
some attack logic first logic and
choices and then at the end of that
we'll assume we won the battle or
whatever and we'll level it up so every
we just need way to basically go through
a program and be leveling up and choose
new skills for safely examples so this
should take care of it we will fill out
the attack logic and choices here
shortly but we gotta see what's going on
here first in order to do that so we can
assume that your first attack say if
there's no chosen skill tree or well I
guess we could do it the opposite way if
there is a skill tree then we're going
to have some additional options
otherwise
we'll just do a basic attack
and we'll fix this logic up later if we
need to and we'll put it just uh we'll
see out here for level up and don't
worry we'll get to the the game Loop
here down in the main later but first we
need to kind of work out this system at
least a little bit
and so far we're doing so good so let's
hypothesize a little bit how are we
going to use this swordsman well in some
point we're going to instantiate at some
point we're going to do an attack then
after that attack uh well we're going to
go through this and that's going to
start it all basically it's just going
through this attack because we're just
assuming you have to attack to level up
in our very naive example all right so
let's work through this level up you get
a skill point and if you haven't chosen
a skill tree yet
you're automatically going to become a
Swordsman
and then you're gonna gain a skill now
we have to kind of consider um skill
points
so we'll we'll have to say we'll have to
do something with how many skill points
you have and how many points you've
spent so basically
what we want to do here is we want to
say if
points spent it's less than the number
that you have skill points
that's when you would gain a skill if
you've already spent them all you're not
going to gain any more skills So based
on this we need to very carefully
analyze this now our Max we have a
maximum we have a Max skill points and
right now that's four that's just based
on our naive design obviously that's
gonna that's gonna change a lot so we
can have or we can say you know maybe
this should actually go somewhere else
because what if later we get higher
levels and we go down other trees I
don't know you decide how you want to do
that dynamically but maybe we'll
actually put that in this sword special
Max skill points four and this one we
might actually want private and we'll do
it const this is going to be basically
hard coded in here you can only put four
points in this tree let's go ahead and
make it private so we will be
referencing these Max skill points a
little later uh specifically in this
gain skill to make sure that they
haven't spent too many but anytime you
level up you're going to get a new skill
point So eventually you'll go over more
than four skill points but in any case
you're still gonna only be allowed to
put four into this tree so hopefully
that makes sense that just basically
allows us to expand later and add more
skills into the tree or add other skill
trees there are some way to spend your
points but in our case we're only
allowing you to spend those four and
swordsman Tree in this naive example
and we're also going to do another thing
here well when you first choose the new
skill tree when you first go into this
tree we're going to say you spent the
point going into that tree so there we
go so that should set it the very first
time to uh one skill point and one point
spent but later when this gets skipped
because you've already got the tree like
uh for example on the second level your
skill points is going to go to two
and your skill point spent is still
going to be one so you just got to kind
of consider these options and in that
case we're going to be in this block and
the point spin is going to be less than
the skill points so we'll go to gain
scale
and we will also be doing a few other
things like we need to consider the max
skill points here uh that's that's maybe
a little weird uh because well it's
hard-coded in the gain skill so I'm
gonna call this anyway and then just
reject I think so I think in our case
we'll just we'll just put a return we'll
put like it um
I guess we gotta kind of decide where
we're gonna gonna put this yeah we're
gonna change some things here briefly
um but I think we'll go something along
the lines of uh yeah I guess we just
need Point spent into this tree as well
so we'll just make that private points
into tree and we'll just start that out
as zero but after you gain a skill at
the very end you're gonna go points into
three plus plus
right and at the very beginning of this
we want to make sure that they're not
maxed out so right off the bat we'll
just go if uh points in the tree is
greater than or equal to the max skill
points we can't do anything here we'll
just return so basically if you try to
gain a skill when you've already maxed
out this tree it's just going to return
and not do anything otherwise we want to
learn some abilities via player choice
if there is a choice
and then uh Upstate this points in a
tree so there might be a few flaws in
this design as I'm definitely just doing
it somewhat off the top of my head but
we'll try to address as many of those as
we can in the allotted time but for now
let's just continue with the example so
let's say all right we're we're playing
the game we're attacking we're leveling
up and we're gaining skills so far so
good it's uh it's really it's really not
too bad we just need to make sure this
point spent works properly
um let's see
if the point span is less than the skill
points we gain a skill if we
successfully gain a skill we need to
uptick the point spent so let's say this
gain skill returns a bull returns true
returns
through if Point spent successfully
now this should actually help a lot
because we could actually save up points
because we could in theory have an
option here that says don't spend and
it'll just back out of the function and
next time you go to level up you'll have
two skill points so I don't know
optionally we can do something like that
but now we want to make sure that if we
fail to spend we'll return false in that
if we succeed in spending we return true
so we'll just do that at the end like so
this type of function with multiple
returns might go against some kind of
standard some some standards say or you
know some organizations will say you can
only have one return statement in your
function just for clarity we're going to
have a bunch in ours so your
organization might be strictly against
the source setup but you can adjust if
needed and uh reason about it however
you need to but we're going to keep
going
and that's just going to allow us here
to
go yeah so if this returns true and they
spent the point we'll go points spent
plus plus and if they didn't it's just
going to fall through and the point
spent will not go up and I think we're
getting close to about everything we
need here so let's just start filling
out some logic we're going to forget
about this attack for just a moment and
just look at this gain scalability now
you could say yeah this logic is going
to get a little bit complicated very
quickly but as you can see
um we basically have a tier one a tier
two and a tier three so we could break
it up a little bit based on that all
right because we got
we have some things here like damage or
accuracy that's in tier one you can't
have them both so in order to say we
can't have the boat we could take this
damage uh This plus damage here in this
accuracy here and combine them together
into something like an enum we could
have Edom uh tier one and tier one could
either be plus damage
or we'll rename this plus accuracy so
now
your tier one is going to be one or the
other
but it can't be both and it could also
be unspent all right so either tier
one's unspent has plus damage or plus
accuracy all right and we can do a
similar thing for tier two it's either
power attack or stable strike all right
so I'm just going to copy this line down
change it to tier two change that to
tier two and put in here power attack or
state strike and now we can delete these
here and we also do the same thing for
the tier three or the final one we now
have four choices so we could make a
tier three that has four choices start
the first one as unspent and the rest
are going to be all these options
but one of the most important things
here is to design it in a way where you
not have error you want it to be
logically impossible to bug this out now
this is something super critical and
that like most games get wrong the sheer
number of bugs and games often comes
from just faulty logic like they're just
they just might have something in the
code where if you go in a specific order
you can magically get some tier 3
ability without spending tier one and
tier two first we want that to be
impossible now
you could still do it with cheats of
course because you could go you know you
could open the binary and change the
memory but that's illegal that's using
hacks so you know that's it's always
going to be possible to change the
memory but
not natively someone would have to be
hacking or you know diving into the
memory and changing stuff not through
the normal program operation so what I'm
talking about here is normal program
operation that's the one that should be
designed in a way where it can't have
logical fallacy now
people are going to hack games there's
nothing you can do about it people are
going to like mess your stuff up via
that method but
it's uh it's not legal and you know
they'll get disqualified from speed runs
and whatever for doing that and called
out and shame who knows yeah watch uh
Carl jobs Channel about that stuff if
you're interested in How uh
people who try to cheat and speed runs
and hack stuff
eventually get caught you know so we're
going to kind of ignore that factor it's
the point I'm getting to but based on
this now we don't have a bunch of
booleans now we have kind of somewhat of
a tiered system already so that is sort
of nice I think this might complain
about something uh we'll see if we'll
get some compiler warnings we need to
correct but I'm not sure if we're
allowed to use this same keyword in all
three of these I think we can if we go
enumclass but also you can see that
these tiers are specifically designed
within sword special they're not outside
of it so no one's gonna have easy access
to these uh we're basically only going
to use it within this function
all right and we're going to use it
within our learn ability choice and this
this is going to get a little bit messy
but if you follow this long you should
be able to reason about the last of this
too
so first of all we're going to assume
the first point is automatic
um if you uh the first time you
instantiate this thing you're spinning a
point
and points in the tree should be one so
actually
you're automatically one point into the
tree if you have the tree at all just
just based on the design because you
automatically you know if you're setting
up to sword specialization you're
spinning that point there then your next
point is the one that's going to start
to matter as far as making choices
so that's what would go here and we can
go off of points into tree to see what
tier they're on
um actually let's reverse this a little
bit it's just going to make the logic a
little confusing points in the tree or
maybe we could call this at tier because
you know since the first one's automatic
we don't really need to uh and we don't
really need to logic that we can just
kind of skip over the logic of that and
in that way Max skill points is three
because three tiers uh so we'll call
this tears into tree and that's going to
make a little bit more sense when we're
reading out our logic so we'll say if
tiers into 3 is less than well let's see
here let me think about this I guess we
just actually need to switch we can just
make a switch statement here switch
on tears into a tree
and we just need to put all the cases on
the handle here case one
so if you're a tier one base two let's
make sure we put breaks in these
um I've been liking to do my switch
statements like this make a scope to
break at the end of it in case three
make a scope break at the end of it now
we don't necessarily need a scope
depends on what you're doing and the
balls we're going to do nothing well I
think if we do a ball through case well
there won't be any fall through it's
going to be logically impossible so
we're assuming if we get here we're
going to force some Choice and then
we're gonna plus plus the tiers into
tree I guess these would be actually one
less if we think about it if you're at
tier zero you're going to gain level one
stuff you're at your one you're going to
gain the level two set because basically
you're going up to the next tier so we
want to assume that you're not there yet
before you you gain the skill if that
makes sense because once we get this
once this pluses to three there's
nothing else to do
were maxed out in the tree all right so
let's think about case Zero uh the first
time you level up your you can either
take damage or accuracy so we want to
make that choice here all right so we'll
say uh let's just put a c out here so
let's make a
let's make a little Choice character
here or what I'm doing backwards
character called Choice started out as
null I guess or just a zero it doesn't
matter really just needs to be some kind
of invalid option maybe we'll make it a
new line character I don't know we'll
figure that out later if we need to all
right but now we need to say
um choose a skill so if we're going into
this we're definitely going to be saying
to the skill so let's just preempt that
here's a place to change place the spin
skill point and which skill point is it
well it's basically going to be this
number uh plus one
so this should say for example when
tears into tree is zero which will be
the very first time it's going to say
choose a place to spin skill point one
and that's where you're going to choose
which tier one damage or accuracy
so we'll go damage plus uh okay so we
assume you know this is going to already
be in the console here
we just need to prompt the option
options here so we'll say like uh
press D for damage
and we can also have in here a for
accuracy I have to look up whether I'm
spelling accuracy correctly
it only has one R okay good so I've been
spilling it wrong
all right so we're basically going to
get this that prompt there choose place
to spin skill D or a and then what we're
going to do is we're gonna go uh CN
choice
and assume that they put in a valid
option so we need to once again have
another little if statement if uh Choice
equals D then we need to say Year One
is now equal to plus damage
also choice equals a tier one equals
plus accuracy
and then we want to be able to we want
to be sure to eat the new line character
this CN is not going to it's basically
going to sit here and do nothing unless
we go
um
CN dot ignore say a hundred it's kind of
a hack basically this just eats the new
line out of the console so that the
program actually continues uh but also
we want to consider what if they press
the wrong buttons what if they press
invalid stuff what if they just enter a
bunch of junk that's something to
something that people can always do and
this gets into a little bit of the
console logic we're going to kind of
shortcut it with this CN ignore but just
keep in mind that if they enter more
than 100 characters of junk that you're
going to get weird stuff happening that
doesn't make any sense so more likely
what's going to happen for you is you
have some sort of interface and they
click a button and you don't have to
worry about the CN dot ignore stop in
the console so much but when you're
pulling in stuff from the console
um CN I believe CN doesn't actually eat
the new line it just it stops either at
a space or a new line so at some point
you gotta like uh get rid of some of
that stuff in the console and that's
what the CN is for now we also want to
say what if they made an invalid choice
and I mean we're not really going to
handle that but basically you would want
to do a loop uh so you want to do like
while uh Choice it's not equal to D and
choice
or choice is not equal to a so if
they've made a wrong choice we continue
and we do it all again that might not
make a ton of sense to you right now but
basically if they put in wrong data and
they don't get either of these we don't
want to like accidentally scale the spin
the skill point and give them nothing we
want to loop back and say try again
basically so this might actually work a
little better this way
and now in theory as of right now we
should be able to gain these new skills
so let's just put a little console out
here just to verbalize it and see if it
actually works plus damage goes on the
board
here one
that's just so we get some visualization
in the command line
and we'll save plus accuracy on this one
we probably want another prompt here
that just shows the user we're waiting
for them with something like this
and that way they get this is the last
thing and then their cursor will be
blinking after this choice and that kind
of tells them that we're waiting for it
all right so maybe we go ahead and give
this initial
thing a test
all right so let's uh go down to our
main and just start out let's let's go
ahead and we'll instantiate a swords mid
uh
we'll just call it our player and we'll
go our player dot attack and we know
what that's going to do as of right now
as of right now when we call attack
um
first of all it's going to see if
they've got a skill tree if not it's
just going to say basic attack if they
don't have a skill tree and then it's
going to level up
and when it levels up it's going to say
level up we don't have a skill tree yet
it's going to automatically spend our
first point into uh sword special and
spend a point there notice that the
skill points are not aligned the same in
these trees as they are in The Swordsman
that's intended it's just the way it's
going to kind of work in our system but
from there so first of all we should
just get sword spec chose if we attack
again we shouldn't get really anything
here we should say well let's say sword
attack just to show something
and then we'll level up again here
but this time it's going to call gain
skill
because we already have a skill tree our
points are going to be misaligned where
we have less
where we have more skill points than
points spent and so we're going to have
a point to spin so that should kick in
there and you know we don't we haven't
programmed in a reject option yet so
this should definitely always return
true as long as we're not getting this
first case where it's false but let's
give it a check let's just see if it
actually works so we're going to go to
this and build for the first time let's
see if we get a successful compile
do you have an error just some kind of
syntax error I think we just need a
semicolon there of some sort we'll put a
break yeah
all right and here we go it flies
through it says basic attack level up
sword spec Chosen and then on our second
attack sword attack level up choose a
place to spin skill point one damage or
accuracy let's say let's put in some
jump data to start we'll say I which
makes no sense right so it should move
back and say diameter accuracy you know
we put in something valid okay we'll
finally say damage and it'll say plus
damage chosen for tier one now we can
see it still Loops out of this or it
still Loops again and uh doesn't seem to
actually oh we need hand
yeah that's why okay which a nice catch
there on the static analysis that
actually underlined it but if the choice
is not D and not a then it's wrong so
that's why it did that so let's stop
this and give it another try and just
make sure it does what we expect
choose damage here and there we go plus
damage chosen for tier one the program
exits because in our main we have
literally nothing after that so that's
what's going to happen but as you can
see this first skill point being chosen
actually works for tier one now it's uh
not actually doing anything for a player
yet but we should in theory let's say
let's make another let's make damage and
accuracy here we'll start them both as
one and we can plus the damage if they
choose damage and we can plus the
accuracy if they choose accuracy so how
are we going to do that that's that's
going to get a little bit trickier here
because we need to return something that
either tells us what to do or we need to
be passing in this Swordsman
so that it can be modified and uh you
know we could also pass in some special
return struct and or maybe some command
or something like that but for sake the
example here I'm going to just pass in
on this uh
gain skill we're gonna pass in this
entire swordsman so that it can be
edited so let's go back up to gainscale
here
um you're still swordsman you know this
should probably have an interface in
front of it called player or something
so that we can just pass in player
that's going to make it more modular
later uh sure I guess we'll do that real
quick let's go to Strike player
and we'll just go over the old white I
feel like this might accidentally
complicate it but this sort of thing
will be required if you have a bunch of
different skill trees because it's not
necessarily it's going to pass in a
swordsman right you might have some
other kind of thing so let's just change
this from swordsman to player instead
just for you know
just so that it reads better basically
so that we know it's a player all right
so this gain skill wants to take in a
player by reference so we just go player
we could do it also by pointer but we're
going to do it by reference in this case
later now we run into a little bit of an
error here because at the point of
um instantiating the skill tree the
program doesn't currently know what
player is
so in fact we are actually going to have
to make this a pointer and we're going
to have to forward declare players
basically this just says Hey expect
um
or using structure we're not using
classes except expect destructive type
player
so later I guess uh
yeah we need to decide some things here
I guess we'll have this just got to
carefully think about the order of how
things are declared here doesn't know
about the player yet
um I guess we would forward declare the
skill tree actually obstruct skill tree
and put all of this before
or after the player
hold on I'm kind of boggling my own
brain here trying to think about this
give me a sec okay let's just fix
everything we can here first
uh let's make sure we get all these
sorted out and when we call gain skill
and we pass it to player since we're in
the player class or struct we just pass
it in this which is a pointer to the
class
now the problem comes in here is right
here when we try to instantiate it but
it doesn't know what player is yet I
think when you put it Forward declare
player if I'm not mistake okay that is
correct we need to forward declare
player because we have these pointers
here and since it's a Pointer's pointer
we don't need the full definition yet
it's going to figure that out later this
basically says expect this uh pointer
type player to be valid and defined
somewhere which it is down below
but now what we can do here is if they
choose the plus damage we can go
player
damage will just up the damage just
directly like that and we can do the
same thing for accuracy okay so one one
thing I'm kind of skipping here is well
this is maybe a little dangerous you
know we're passing player end to the
entire skill tree and we're letting
skill tree do whatever we want with the
player a little bit dangerous but I'm
just going to leave it like that and you
can improve it if you want because what
would be a better idea is probably to
have these be private in the struct and
just have a function that says like
um add damage or plus up damage and
basically to have it under some sort of
control well not just wide open to a a
skill tree because a skill tree could
just say if it wants let's set damage
um equal to one million and it would
just accept it so if we could put some
barricades around that with some some
kind of Setter or you know you probably
get the point here but for sake for
example we're going to keep it as simple
as possible and uh you know passing ends
fine enough we know that our particular
tree is uh valid enough all right so
that takes care of tier one so what
happens if we gain another skill point
well in that case uh we've already got
one skill point we're going to go up to
the next one and that should work so
all right once they get into this skill
tree they absolutely have to choose one
there's no way out of this until they
choose one and once they do that the
tears industry is going to plus plus
that's designed that way on purpose we
don't really have a way to save the
level ups for later you can do that if
you want but we're skipping that logic
here all right
so let's now consider you know we got
more damage
um we'll say let's see basic attack here
sword attack
we can put the damage in actors let's
put the damage and accuracy in here
because we kind of want to know I'll
just put like a d for damage and we'll
just kind of make sure it builds that
out correctly and then we'll put an a
for accuracy so that way we should see
these numbers as we go there we go let's
hit play again and see if that shows
better undefined type player even though
it just worked a second ago okay
um just got to be out with this I I'll I
will go the entire rest of my life and
not understand why it suddenly has a
compiled error now and it didn't before
because
this just worked
and now after I don't know changing a
random C out down here it doesn't okay
but ultimately the problem here is what
we're trying to call from a pointer
player and trying to call something from
within it
um and you know it worked I'm not sure I
guess I'd have to go watch the video but
maybe I wasn't calling anything about
the player before when I compiled before
but it only knows about it in theory it
knows how to exists it doesn't know
anything about what it does at this
point so we have to and this is this is
all because we're trying to Define
things above the main we can solve this
problem very quickly by going
uh we could just forward declare all of
these like so
or just put them all in different
headers
I guess the skill tree one can stay up
here since it's a interface but
everything else needs to know needs to
be defined down below or in a non-header
type fashion so like down here this gets
a little more simplified with multiple
files and proper includes but let's see
if this has happened nope still the same
thing
uh ultimately doesn't know what player
is at this point
let's go ahead and get this fixed okay
so this is often where people get stuck
in C plus plus when they get an error
like this and they don't really know how
to restructure things to make it uh do
what it's supposed to do we just want to
access the player that we're passing in
and we just want to up the damage seems
simple enough now I'm not entirely sure
why I didn't have an error before I
think the reason was is because it was
optimized away because we weren't even
using damage and accuracy anywhere so it
just didn't care and due to
optimizations it took care of it I think
not even 100 sure but now that we're
using these somewhere they definitely
need to uh actually work properly and
when we're passing them in here well
players not defined yet it knows that
hey there's a structural player but it
doesn't know anything about it at this
point so we can't just like call stuff
so there's
a couple different ways we could fix
this and the easiest way is probably to
instead of
passing in a player is to pass in some
sort of
command
well I don't want to make this over
complicated so I think what we're going
to end up doing here is just not passing
it in player at all while we could and
it's a somewhat valid option it's going
to make this a little more confusing so
let's just get rid of passing in player
everything else is going to stay the
same let's get rid of because yeah you
know kind of as I spoke about before we
don't necessarily want this skill tree
to be modifying the player necessarily
so ultimately you know the player
they've got access to the skill tree so
it could be checked
and that's probably what we want to do
ultimately is we want to just base it
off of off of that so we're just going
to have to add in a little bit more
stuff in here and we know that you know
the sword attack damage is going to be
damaged and then it's going to be like
plus skill damage basically and if we
check our skill tree
um yeah we're basically going to need
more logic in here if we check our skill
tree we should be able to get damage and
accuracy added from that as well is the
point
so you might ask okay how do you do that
well we need to take a look at this
sword special that's part of the skill
tree and see if we have either of these
set and while we're at it another thing
we probably want to do is in this Loop
rather than going off this choice we
just want to see if tier one is equal to
unspent if it's unspent
um we do a little comparison here that's
when we know we need to keep asking
because I didn't spin the point yet so
that's just going to be a little bit of
a optimization there and uh also we need
to make sure that these just start out
as they're supposed to be so this should
be tier one on spent and the rest of
these kind of the same except for their
tier because we're going to have similar
Logic for those later and now this
function of attack is going to get a
little more confusing now it's already
kind of a hack basically a hack job but
basically
rather than just taking this roll damage
let's actually make these private so we
don't even have access to them damage
and accuracy we want to get like you
know obviously we have support for
leveling up into uh fix that real quick
we have support for leveling up into the
sword so basically we want some kind of
like Get damage function that will
get everything we expect so we could put
that privately in here and just do a and
get damaged
now the only thing that can call damage
is this attack and we'll do a similar
thing for get accurate take similar
thing here get accuracy there might be a
smarter way of doing this you're welcome
to let me know or just modify the repo
and make a pull request that's all good
but okay so get damaged it's obviously
gonna return the damage plus whatever we
have from skills so we have to consider
what do we have what do we penitentially
have from skills well we already know
about the sword and special struct but
we don't necessarily know what this
skill tree is set as so we'd have to do
well I guess in this case we have to do
some casting which is a little bit slow
and not always recommended but if you
got to do it you got to do it so we
basically would go let's see let's
instantiate a variable here or else
sword specials
spec let's just see if we can cast this
chosen skill tree to a sword special so
we go standard well what is this Dynamic
cast into sword special pointer this
needs to be a point or two we just try
to cast it into that and see if their
chosen skill tree is sword special if so
well let's do get sword damage and get
sword accuracy let's make these a little
more specific since we're you know now
I'm thinking about it it might be better
to do the cast here and check but I
don't know this is still very nice so it
is what it is but we could basically say
if the skill tree is set if if the spec
exists because this will be null if the
cast failed
uh will we know if Cass failed so if if
there is a spec Mom let's return
um let's see what are we looking at here
again we want to see if tier one is set
to plus damage basically return
I guess we can put this all in one line
damage plus uh well let's not make it
too complicated let's simplify the logic
a little bit here so let's make a
variable and well we know we already
know we're going to get this damage we
don't need to do anything about that
what we need to know whether we're
getting the bonus damage from this plus
damage or not so the way we do that is
we go
um
if spec
um well then we can check specialization
we have spec dot ear one and C which is
equal to is plus damage tier one plus
damage we also need to scope this into
sword special that's where we're getting
that enum of course declared so if it's
plus damage we're going to return damage
plus one next spell is wrong
yes I did okay so if they have the sword
specialization uh well it's not return
yet this is we're making this a little
more confusing than we do that's first
of all let's just write up here let's
just go and total damage and let's just
start it out as the actual damage
because maybe things later we'll
increase that so let's just started out
as the damage but let's make sure we
plus it up if this case is true total
damage
plus equals we'll just say one one's
fine so there we go
uh when we go to get damage well
we're going to start with the normal
damage then we're going to check if they
have the sword specialization and if
they do we're going to see if they've
got the plus damage and if we if they do
we had some damage to Total damage we're
just going to return total damage it
should be pretty infallible because if
they don't have this specialization this
entire block will get skipped and then
just return here now we got to be a
little careful here because we could be
leaking memory if they do have the
specialization we are filling out a
pointer
and that is going to basically leak
memory if not deleted so we want to
check here if there was a specialization
after we plus up this damage if it was
required uh then we want to delete this
might be a little different than we
expect and basically the short answer is
hey you should not delete either pointer
it's an undefined Behavior to do so so
basically we're kind of deleting the
original when we do this so I was a
little mistaken on this delete don't
delete these Dynamic tasks because it's
going to delete your entire skill tree
um I guess that's just the way it's
designed is this going to be a memory
leak I don't think so but I don't know
if you've got a sample of something you
want to show me about that or us rather
you can but now you can see it doesn't
error out okay so we did a basic attack
we leveled up we chose the sword spec we
did another attack this time damage one
accuracy one now we get to level up and
let's level up damage and we get the
plus damage blue what we want to do next
is do another attack so let's go ahead
and do that and we should see that this
one either has more damage or more
accuracy based on what we choose choose
here so let's hit damage and now we see
we do two damage we get another level up
but the program ends at that point
because we haven't programmed it so
we've got tier one sorted out there
based on this example you should be able
to fill out how this next tier works I'm
out of time for this video but basically
you want to do a very similar thing as
this case except rather plus damage or
plus accuracy they're going to
automatically gain power attack or
automatically gain stable strike because
if their tier one was previously plus
damage and they have another point it's
automatically going to go into Power
Attack because there's nothing else
um I guess I could do that I'll just do
it real quick let's not be too lazy here
so we basically just want an if here if
uh tier one is uh the plus damage
foreign
Tech
make sure you get your equal signs right
and we'll do an l-sif here one
and I'm rather than just doing else I am
doing LSAT because if somehow they got
here with unspent we want to make sure
that's defined although logically
impossible
um but it's not hurting anything
might be a little less efficient but
likely optimized away in a release build
anyway so there we go so if they
previously chose accuracy then they're
going to get the other one
which is stable skirt and that'll be
that there's not even a prompt for
anything but we do need to consider now
when you attack you could could choose
power attack or stable strike so you
basically need to work that into here
rather than just plain old sword attack
and damage and accuracy it's like now
you have an option do you want to do
power attack or do you want to do your
special strike and are you going to have
one or the other you're not both so
you'd rather than just straight going to
this attack you're just going to need
more options you're basically going to
need a basic attack and then you're
going to need
the other special attack one of these
others and if you choose one of these
others you might want to put it on
cooldown and say you can't choose it
twice in a row you can only attack every
other time or something like that so the
logic continues and now you can see how
tier this last tier level up would go if
they're going down the damage side
they're going to have to choose one or
one of these two so you want to prompt
one of these two a similar prompt to
this just need to make sure they're on
the power side and same with over here
if they're on the accuracy side you want
to prompt one of these two and then you
need to adjust accordingly for your
abilities based on those chosen skills
so I'm going to leave that someone else
to fill out the rest sure I could do it
but it's basically kind of repeating
what we've already done
um but yeah this is the reality of skill
trees you basically do kind of a Cascade
of options based on the previous chosen
things and you need to carefully analyze
what you're how you're doing it so this
is a very Brute Force way right here but
it'll get the job done there might be
better ways with some sort of State
machine or I don't know I'm trying to
think of a good way or maybe some sort
of there might be some pattern you could
work into this that would that would do
well but if it were me I'd probably you
know in this small case here I kind of
like the brute force method because it's
it's very easy to read it's very easy to
reason about because it's really only
got one option based on what you've
previously done so in a way it is a
state machine it just gets to look a
little messy mainly for me it's the cnnc
outs that start to look messy so in your
real thing you're probably going to have
this abstracted into another class that
doesn't have all this console and
console out I hope that makes sense I'm
going to go ahead and push this code and
leave a link and you can let me know
your thoughts below let me know what you
think of this skill tree also just want
to point out here that I have this
program I wrote when I was in school
called DM power
um and it basically uses a ton of stuff
like this uh there's there's a ton of
these little logic trees of different
Cascades going
um it's basically a fifth edition d d
character generator type thing but it's
got tons of this stuff built in so this
is where I got a lot of my initial
practice was just figuring out how to do
this because you know based on this
based on what race you are what class
you are what level you are what
specializations you've chosen you get a
lot of different options and that's all
programmed in here so I've been I've
been through the weeds many times on
this sort of stuff so if you want to see
like a full working example of this kind
of stuff I've got one right here in this
public repo
700 lines of of code of working out
logic of different choices of stuff and
that's that's only for campaign there's
also you know characters a lot of stuff
about updating a lot of stuff about
leveling up gen generating rewards all
sorts of stuff all the different race
options it's all in here so you know if
you really want to see a really kind of
more complete robust example or maybe
just how to make a fifth edition
character generator and maintainer check
out this repo I use it all the time when
I'm playing Dungeons and Dragons it's
it's just super handy for uh preparing
and running games and maintaining PCS
and stuff like that and coming up with
Luke it does a lot of it for you and
just the console but you know it's kind
of a similar thing as to what we're
doing here or getting started with
however I don't use any Dynamic casts in
that so you won't see anything like this
but I probably could have saved quite a
few lines of code if I did use Dynamic
cast but then again it would also be a
little bit slower so you know based on
what options you choose you're going to
have some advantages and disadvantages
but I hope you've enjoyed this example
and I've maybe learned something I'll
see you guys on the next episode peace
out